This has been the best
Christmas with you guys.
Let's make Christmas Eve
dinner our tradition.
I think I speak for our family
when I say we are in.
Everyone say pumpkin cheesecake!
In the town of North Pole,
we know how to do Christmas.
And for me and my best friend,
there is no competition.
You're Trish and Diana,
the unstoppable duo who wins the
home decorating contest every Christmas.
Diana is the yin to my yang.
But when the whole season
is about going over the top.
I have held this title for ten years.
I'm not letting someone else
take it from me now.
I just feel like you're always pushing me.
What is that supposed to mean?
It's not always about winning.
It's easy to go too far.
Oh my god!
Please tell me you got that.
Oh, btw
we are no longer on
speaking terms with the Riveras.
If our moms break up,
they're gonna be on us even more.
I've got an idea.
- Hey guys.
- Look who's here?
Look at all of us!
Like the good old days!
You are so not winning
that golden reindeer this year.
Who's going to stop me?
I am.
I have to show Diana
that I could win without her.
A supermodel snow woman.
Is that my swimsuit?
So good.
Men and women hanging out
after eight on a weekend is a date.
Well, we should wrap this up fast then.
It's hard because
she's always been there for me.
We were a team.
Our moms will kill us.
Do not bring up our moms or...
She just got pegged by Santa!
Mrs. Logan,
I really need that reindeer.
Oh, I'm sorry.
This is for my granddaughter.
Mrs. Logan!
Where is your holiday spirit?
No!
This town is ruthless.